bien
45 años después de la muerte del
dictador de españa francisco franco el
consejo de ministros aprobó el
anteproyecto de una nueva ley de memoria
histórica con la que busca paliar los
vacíos señalados por organismos como
naciones unidas el reconocimiento la
reparación la dignidad y la justicia
para la víctima para nuestros
compatriotas que el momento difícil
lucharon contra el fascismo en muchos
casos perdieron las vidas de muy
diversas maneras esta nueva ley de 66
artículos sustituye la de 2007 e incluir
a la responsabilidad del estado de
exhumar las fosas comunes donde aún
quedan decenas de miles de víctimas y ge
y anulara sentencias franquistas tras la
aprobación del consejo de ministros la
ley tendrá que recibir luz verde del
congreso
es la primera peluquera de hombres del
sur de irak un sign up ignoró las
críticas y consiguió formar su propio
grupo de clientes habituales soy parte
de la sociedad soy como cualquier otra
mujer salgo a trabajar para mantener a
mi familia cuando veo a mis amigas les
digo que no deben quedarse en casa o no
fallece el propietario del local recibió
quejas por contratar a un sign up sin
embargo los ignoró y decidió apostar por
la igualdad
[Música]
cuexcomatitlán en méxico se convierte en
una torre de babel moderna elizabeth
valdez habría una biblioteca en su casa
para niños allí se enseña español y
lenguas indígenas de las siete etnias
que llegaron a la ciudad en busca de
trabajo y entonces pues para mí se me
hace muy bien porque ya se ven como
familia no lo que yo siempre les he
dicho que cualquier etnia o lo que no
sean a más de nosotros todos somos
hermanos o hermanos indígenas se trata
de un esfuerzo colectivo que tiene por
objetivo el entendimiento de los pueblos
indígenas a partir de la suma cultural
con la mezcla de las lenguas autom y
mixteco maya purépecha triqui huasteca y
wixárika
[Música]
en brásil distintas comunidades se están
organizando para salvar de la quiebra
las librerías de barrio
cuando se cierra una librería de barrio
se cierra un centro de cultura cerrar
una de estas librerías es como serra le
la biblioteca al barrio entre las
iniciativas está el lanzamiento
anticipado de obras la recaudación de
fondos para sufragar el alquiler así
como ayudas de financiación de la cámara
brasileña del libro
la ola más grande del año surfeada por
una mujer la brasileña maya gabeira
consiguió surfear una ola de más de 22
metros en portugal de esta forma
consiguió el récord del mundo de la ola
más grande surfeada por una mujer
the rolling stones continúan haciendo
historia por sexta década volvieron a
obtener el número uno en el reino unido-
es el primer grupo que lo consigue y ya
suman 13 álbumes en la cima de la música
británica
[Música]
y